okay for people joining this live stream
we are looking at some future
ideas for language which um
uh
may or may not be i think these are post
13.1 for the most part
uh all right we're looking at
the concept of supplied
so
magnification a bit i'm having a bit
trouble seeing that actually on my
laptop
why it
usually usually should be fine okay all
right okay
um all right
for people who've been working with this
dollar dollar business how is it feeling
it's a little bit
ponderous looking
well i don't think we've really
implemented anything
uh we've implemented a version of
supplied entry map which is the next
agenda item but there was this
um
[Music]
i mean we could we could do a a bit of
illusion of those dollar dollar things
in terms of typesetting
but i mean this is something you would
be typing in right i i don't know that
that would yeah i know it just looks
kind of ugly in the code i mean we could
make it we could stylize it slightly in
terms of its display
so i don't think i was here for the last
meeting i mean why is it a double dollar
sign
because we want to separate it from
other things
and because we think there may be a lot
of these
right we want to have them in their own
sort of space in a sense
right so they're not sort of dollar
variables they're sort of magic
how many functions are gonna
provide it
provide what
i mean make use of it right yeah
lots in the end
i mean it will gradually expand
i mean probably most functions that take
a function as an argument could support
supplied
yeah
i mean there's going to be list
manipulation
mobile binding is it
yeah i hope it's not
super global
it's
look what it is
is it's got to go in
and upon evaluation here
it's got to be able to this thing should
be colon equaled effectively
to a thing that goes and
hunts
its
you know internal data structure that
represents the index in the map
and makes use of it
it's not like it's not like if you go
and you know it's lexical right so it's
got to be there
it's not going to go down in some sub
thing of some some sub piece of this
deeply nested where there's an index
there
there's that issue and there's the issue
of parallelism
right that that i guess
well right i mean it sounds like
basically the idea is that it's
effectively like a module variable
where it'll be sort of localized to
lexically localized
it's more like a width variable than a
module variable well i say module just
because i think the idea was that it
would be lazy it would be kind of set
delayed like as opposed to so you don't
actually have to compute the index or
whatever it is
it's not going to be absolutely used
right well well but i i think the idea
right so so look at the second you know
i think since we're still not agreed on
what this is right so here's
this one here yes
okay
right
so
right
so the dollar dollar index gets
immediately replaced before the function
gets anything that's correct the one
that's good as far as i'm concerned
that's better than what i was kind of
implying with a you know almost dynamic
binding type thing right but so is it
still uh
sort of lazily computed i mean in index
it doesn't matter but if there's
something more expensive than index it
might
i think it should be computed only
only look you're not going to compute
the whole list of 20 of these things and
then do a width on them
if that's what you're asking the it'll
have to scan this
for the lexical presence of these things
right
fine yeah
there isn't a way of passing in some
argument that's an association
we don't want that because we don't want
to pre-compute the association
right i mean this is the original idea
that the problem is both that you have
to pre you have to compute all the
fields of the association every time and
they might not be as cheap as index and
then two that you have to actually
construct the association which is
actually a significant slowdown
it also means that like for i i did some
benchmarking with with like map indexed
and so of course because map indexed
map indexed never compiles its its
function unlike map because it takes you
know because its second argument is some
uncompilable format and
it you know if you do certain operations
it's like dramatically slower so that
would be another reason
it's sort of in the same vein as is why
you don't want to always be passing in
some giant association
right i also think it's nice to be able
to do this thing where you don't have to
uh pre-armor-plate this function like
with supplied for instance can you look
at the second from the bottom input
where you have just map of dollar dollar
index
yeah what's wrong with that so the point
is this isn't
reliant on the evaluator
so it's it you you see the dollar dollar
index is changing
i see it but how did you do that i mean
is this or is this just you just type
they're all fake they're all fake
nothing has been implemented well it's
because it's changing the expression
itself not the arguments that it gets
it's effectively you know yes right
normally you have to you know you pass
it a pure function that's the variable
scope you imagine there's another level
of pure function around the pure
function you give it that's replacing
all of these uh
you know index and so on
yes
i i get it right i mean that's like
supplied is doing
and if it's map at level two what's the
index
i think the idea is there's position
yeah those dollar index will be the last
uh uh value there's another one that's
the list yeah
i mean this is why you don't want to
construct the association and why you
want to be lazy because there might be
like i mean for map i think we've talked
about probably like
five to ten different things it could
give yeah like fraction complete like
you know all kinds of stuff
um depth
which wouldn't be very interesting if
you know for
um
well it might if you're mapping at
multiple levels no absolutely it's
interesting if it's a map all type thing
it absolutely is worth knowing what the
depth is
it just doesn't you know i just was i
didn't finish my sentence in this case
it wasn't interesting
right um
okay so
i mean the question here is
okay
so i mean do we think we understand the
concept here i don't you know
implementation is not obvious to me but
the concept would be
that there are a whole family of dollar
dollar variables which for a function
like map we would document a block of
variables
that are the things that are temporarily
set we can call them
environment variables maybe that that
may be confusing that's super confusing
right i mean that that was the working
name we gave to them at you know one or
two meetings ago but i don't think
anybody is is going to champion that
name okay well fine supplied variables
contextual variables
yeah contextual variables is
closer
except for our contexts
getting the word bound into them might
be useful like comments because they're
not bound they're not allowed
they get by
they're always
i bound think that's a useful way to
think about it i think that's a i think
what it more is the main point here is
that it is giving you
as christopher says it's giving you
context for what's going on
i mean maybe it's worth looking at me we
had like 75 different possible names for
supplied maybe it's worth looking at
what those names were because i think
it's
no no supplied is is different from
environment variables although there is
this potential interaction between them
which is this
you know before before i realized we
weren't even all on the same page about
what environment variables were i
thought was going to be the discussion
point
well okay so hold on the
um
i mean by the way this dollar dollar
index thing whatever it is
there's also cases in rules where this
should be used
the idea was that environment variables
would work on the right let's not call
it an environment variable let's call
them contextual variables
okay
the idea was that they would work on the
right-hand side of rules and yeah right
but i think environment variables is
actually a bad name
okay
yeah
uh
okay
so
so then okay
question does somebody know how to
implement these assuming that this
design is what we want but somebody know
how to implement them
i don't think that's at all clear
and it probably will need to be done
function by function
okay i mean what would happen that the
this thing is going to be scanned in
some way with some optimized
hashing type thing to know whether there
are these things in it if there are it
does this et cetera et cetera et cetera
right i mean i think i think that's the
only way we need to let so lexically
scan the input just like in sort of
supply do we like cyclic
uh lexically scan things and then the
question is how do supplied and
contextual variables interact which is
sort of okay i've got an outrageous
suggestion
okay okay
which is
to actually change this at paris
time if we see dollar dollar variables
that's
that's a macro language you're talking
about there it shouldn't be a past time
it should be at a phase in between
parsing
and
okay okay okay
hear me out okay
basic point is
that i don't want us to have to at run
time go through every single maps
you know
function
payload
and you know examine things about it i
mean maybe it's maybe it's stored in
some kind of internal bits and things
but which would be fun you might have to
because the function might be passed in
you know it might be f equals a function
and then you do math
well i thought the idea is that would be
lexical
so that wouldn't work well that would
work
that would work if it's f equals it will
if if it's f you know if it's if it's an
value it absolutely would work right
because map doesn't hold anything so
lexical with respect to the map or the
function
christopher
well
my macro
that won't work i mean there are some
cases where they're sort of parsing them
are these lexical with respect to the
map or the function
i think it's with respect to
the map
right because there isn't necessarily
any function right as we see in the
second to last example
um
but but i mean i think
right i mean
yeah i i think that the sort of macro
thing
is sort of a bad idea in the sense that
it introduces this whole giant you know
it's a bad idea all the absurdity but it
is also i think that there are related
issues like for example with confirm
you know confirm and close there are
related things about well how do you
efficiently replace the confirms and you
kind of want to do that in a somewhat
lazy way
and and so on
and
yeah right i mean there's
i feel like we generally speaking we
probably could have better uh sort of
top level functionality for doing this
kind of lexical
scoping replacement
fair enough i mean that that relates to
things in the extra struts and so on
that store potential information about
what's inside there and so on
but okay let's
um
so tentatively
we think
there are still holes in this if it's
lexical with respect to the map does
that mean map has to hold its first
argument no
no
and it can't be
it can't be because matt won't know
what's there
what do you mean
right so if i type f equals you know one
of those functions with a dollar index
in it
the map of f
does that
you know does the index is it active or
not
it
time of is
right the thing about is map is
effectively running replace all on its
first argument for each iteration so
it's not really lexical it's not a
lexical feature of map
it's it's it's in the function that's
there
but it's lexical in the function as in
it looks at
what
it's lexical and that if your function
if you wrote a function
right
you're somewhat right i mean it's it's
lexical in the sense that if i wrote a
function
with down values or if i wrote you know
f of
ampersand and f used dollar dollar index
then it wouldn't work
so it's not dynamic impossible to use
caching so that's for efficiency it
would be possible to use some sort of
you know weak
cash mechanism
on the
thing so you wouldn't have to repeatedly
do this
fair enough you just have to do it once
sorry what happens at higher levels
what do you mean at higher levels
what is dollar dollar index
if i'm mapping at level two into the
vlog we discuss that
one
it's the index is last of position which
i guess means i don't know what it is if
you
map at level zero
for tree map
i'm i'm using none which
whatever i mean that's that's
um
the point is just to make it clear
we made a list previously i don't know
where it is
of possible dollar dollar contextual
variables which include things like
fraction complete that's in the supplied
ref page there's a futurist page
you make that bigger
yep
yeah i mean so there's all kinds of junk
here
and there's even some like for fold
so another right i mean this fold one
i'm i'm guessing that it also some of
these require that fold store
information that wouldn't otherwise
i think so and by the way i don't know
how we really make this work
well this is for supplied but a dollar
dollar results yeah that's fair point
for environment variables i don't
contextual variables
yeah sorry
i mean maybe they could have uh
they could have sub values or i guess
the down values like maybe but it's sort
of
entering a whole bunch of other crazy
stuff if you do that
i mean there was an earlier alternative
design for them before the dollar dollar
idea which was that there'd be some
word i mean you'd say like you know
contextual variable of quotes result and
then of course you could have subsequent
arguments but it sounds like we moved
away from there i think we've moved away
from that
unless
unless
we made this thing
actually be
change that syntax
to something where this is a prefix
function
and where this like
like message for example picks up a
string thing and where there is a full
form version of this
i think that behavior of message name is
usually very annoying and weird
honestly
okay
well okay but i mean that that's the
alternative here is that this could be
let's imagine it was
my gosh we're really running out of
characters here um
maybe we need to get out the apl book
[Laughter]
um
all right i'm gonna make up just for the
sake of having something hash
back tick that's probably not even
allowed um
okay back tech star
that probably just break out random
choice if you you know at this point
yeah right
um
star is right uh absolutely possible
right if you have one
yeah right okay well look let's say x
times star and i know that's possible
for other things right i know that could
be a
multiplication of a factorial but but
let's just assume it was something like
this
and that that turns into
you know
contextualized
index or something
um
i don't think it's completely crazy to
imagine some kind of of um
if if we could come up with a syntax i
don't think that's completely crazy as
an alternative to these variables like
this
but i kind of prefer it if we if we
could come up with an ascified syntax
even though
look i mean less than less than works
okay with the with string names i think
unless it's a total model about what
comes at the end of it well okay this
works okay with string names okay
and this would want to be something a
bit like that
i mean that's how this all started with
the idea of using hash index
right which won't work
as such
right
and it's much better to have just this
thing whose value is index
um
maybe this could be something that has
both the pre and you know an open and a
close
i see got his suggestions
not really
i mean they're they're more open and
close yeah you know colon greater colon
less than you know bracket you know
colon yeah right i mean there's a
several of these but they they're all
very arbitrary is the problem
oh looks quite nice i mean i could
imagine if you saw that and we we
stylized that nicely i can imagine that
looking perfectly reasonable
is that a bracket or a brace i can't
quite tell it this side it's a bracket
why why is everybody having a hard time
seeing my screens
well i i'm on
on a laptop today because
of reasons so things are smaller than
usual okay okay fine
the okay but i don't have my my nice 4k
monitor right now um okay
then
that looks quite nice it looks like a
goofy smiley face if you turn your head
sideways
well yes
but
i don't think that's horrible syntax
wise but and if we did that
i mean actually i'm kind of liking that
a little bit better than having a what
looks like a global variable
all right but but
if we introduce syntax like this though
i feel like we need to have a proper
like
you know this is a language construct
it's not just sort of like a
function level
construct like i think we need to have
top-level functions that let you
implement this for your own functions
and stuff like that yes okay how would
we do that and and maybe one question is
how do we how do we do that in a way
that we're not basically implementing a
whole parallel system
to pure functions that's effectively the
same
except as different syntax
well how would you specify the function
let's say you have your own function
you know my map
and how would you
go ahead sorry to interrupt but i was
just going to point out that
uh
you know
there's also supplied i mean if we're
making this so meta i wonder if we still
want supplied which i guess supply it
serves a slightly different need yeah so
i i think if we did this then supplied
could just still work with strings in
the first argument
and you would use those same strings and
contextualized
yes for this behavior
remind me why supplied is different
so supplied is for function like things
and it changes what arguments the thing
gets wrapped around
instead of changing the thing itself
right so
maybe if you
look at
um
very first very first in out
of what
of of
of this
section
i mean this one here
right
so
um
right so i mean there's this question of
what happens if you literally insert one
of these contextual variables inside of
supplied but setting that aside you see
how the pound two
gets
replaced with one and two and three here
because not the
so that's right that allows you to sort
of reuse a multivariate function
by sort of rewriting what arguments are
fed
to it so that's what supply does for you
right so supplied of quotes index turns
map into map indexed
yes well well of course position
but yes
okay right so map
map index somewhat confusingly
is
map of supplied
position
oops
f yep
yeah that's sort of interesting so now
written out in the other way that will
be map of f of hash comma
um
which is also not terrible i agree that
these would be similar but they
are they're different they're slightly
different
okay
to christopher's point for either of
them
how do you provide
well
in the first
how would you provide how would you make
a pattern i mean this is like an options
pattern type thing which i always find a
little hard to use but but how would you
write a pattern
that says map
so i think what you want to do is you
want to be able you want to have a
function where you give it
the the supplied the function wrapped
and supplied and then you give it some
kind of like association or something
where you basically tell it here all the
different supplied variables that might
be asked for and here's why i want you
to get you know evaluate to get their
values but you know make sure you
evaluate them in a kind of lazy but
efficient and caching way
but then i claim what that is going to
be is something more like options
pattern where you say map of supplied
pattern of f blank comma blah blah blah
call on equals and that has to be the
thing that will match
you know a supplied pattern has to match
supplied of blah
and so on
and then pick up the variables correctly
i'm so there are no new language
features that need to be added in order
for users to implement supply on their
own
well but i think the point is we want
some infrastructure because you know for
example the fact that you know supplied
of a string in the first argument does
the thing it does is
you know
well that's what i'm saying supplied can
just be implemented you know the same
way you define any kind of pattern
matching thing it's the
the contextual variables
that the users don't have a way to
define themselves no no right of course
of course but it's just inconvenient and
yeah
supplied unless it immediately goes to a
canonical form it's not easy to
implement
right because i mean
go ahead
yeah i would argue doing it through pat
the pattern matching phase is is not
super useful
especially because it's not even
yeah i mean i i it seems to me like it's
more it's more of a
like
supplied is something that's kind of
like a function but it's not it's you
know a wrapped function and just as you
can use apply to apply function i think
there should be some like
supplied apply or something like that
apply supplies that kind of will apply
it and intelligently you know feed in
the correct inputs
except that it can only happen
context there's no reason that this
there's no reason that that supply can
only be used in the arguments to
function anyway like yes yes no
absolutely supplied cannot
you can't just take a supplied and then
apply it to some arguments it means
nothing no right
or on the right-hand side like a vertex
shape function
could be a supplied right but i'm just
saying that there's there could be a
more general function called like apply
supplied or something like that which is
how i mean which is conceptually how you
would implement this if you were
implementing your own version of map or
whatever
where would it get its arguments well i
guess i don't understand that claim
because
i i think it precisely can't exist like
that no it's the argument's structure
give it the explicit content it's not
the argument structure of apply it's if
you give it the supplied object or a
function and you know it would of course
automatically promote it to a supplied
object
then you give it you know the the
arguments that you know for example that
map traditionally gives you a hash one
hash two or something like that and then
you give it some sort of like
association or something where you
basically tell it here's how to get you
know
if you need to know what the index is
here's how you can get it if you need to
know what this is just saying you get it
and so on
and then it just you know looks at the
supply looks at its first argument and
supply and feeds the correct things to
it
so you'd have to compute an association
you have no no you'd have to give it an
association that like i i don't know
exactly what the right structure for
that would be but you'd give it you
would not you would not give it an
association for each iteration you would
sort of somehow
right i see i mean you need to i mean i
wouldn't structure i guess i i just
don't see how i would use apply supplied
to implement supplied
given the way that i implemented it
already
which is about conducting associations
it's just lazily
you know i just have a pattern
and i know what the elements are and
then i replace them at the last second
this requires more thought what should
we what should we look at right now
because this is going to require more
offline thought
i think we've got go ahead right so i
mean the one thing on this agenda that's
important for 131 is that you know we
did implement
a supply for tree map
and so you know we need to review that
and you know
are we okay if if supplied is only going
to exist in this one experimental
function are we okay
not having a rough page for supplied
i'm not keen on this
i mean how important is it
i mean
well so we already removed all the code
and documentation for extended level
specs
and so this is
like a better version of that we used to
say level spec arrow and then you could
say data or subtree
but now this effectively can do map
indexed and all of these other things as
well
are we really happy with the name
supplied
wouldn't contextualize be better except
it's longer
we considered that was rejected for some
reason
i don't remember what context probably
you're thinking having a name that more
closely
is in line with the name that we're
saying for the contextual variables
but i'm not sure that that's right
either
yeah and i'm not sure it's you know if
the idea is these are two different
things then i don't think giving them
the same name is a good idea well i
think the strings are the same
but it's that supplied is for the
arguments and contextual variables is
for the expression so any way we can get
away in this version with some ornate
syntax for tree map that doesn't
introduce the supplied function
we use rule
probably
i mean then you can't map a rule but
well there are ways around that right
with like you hold pattern or verbatim
of the rule just like you do in
in
in cases i mean you'd have to work a
little bit extra to catch that case but
the only problem is that i can see
you know then that syntax is not
oh boy i'm not happy with this because
this syntax is very bleeding edge and
flaky
is there any wrapper that we could
provide
i mean unfortunately more or less any
function f could go in that first
argument
right
what is the defensive way to do
this could put it back into the level
spec
for now
which would work how
you say level spec arrow lms
and just have the elements work
the way supplied is working in terms of
you know if you don't have a list it's
an additional argument if you do have a
list it's a sequence of arguments
i think that would be the more defensive
thing to do
anybody else got comments on that i just
don't think it's the right thing to
introduce this this you know
hair on the tail of the
giant dog where we're only introducing
the hair of the tail
i either way we'll break the level spec
arrow notation that we had before so
from the perspective of trees
either is fine which notation that we
have before
in in 1301 earlier you can say level
spec arrow lm
and that is equivalent to
supplied of a singleton list containing
lm what that's already in
what do you mean like it's already in
released versions is this level spec
arrow syntax yeah the level spec arrow
syntax is in released versions but it
it does not behave the same way the
supply behaves
why it's effectively list lm
it it replaces the one argument that you
have with a different one
whereas supplied of lm
is an additional argument
in addition to the data actually
what do we think is more useful
i think the additional argument is
probably more useful but i mean but i
think if
you know if it's just a matter of having
yeah i i think it's it's not so tragic
that with this older syntax to have to
write more stuff
you know it seems like that we should
keep it that way
you can grandfather this older syntax
for now i mean i don't think that's it's
not harmful is it
i'm saying i can keep the syntax but
i'll have to change the behavior of the
syntax
no but only if you only if subtree is
reused as an element it is a data
subtree and original subtree are used
and supplied and then we added a bunch
of well
so why why do you have to change the it
can't just be that if you want this two
argument behavior you just write more
stuff you just write i don't know what
it is quote sub tree comma get rid of
the additional argument thing for now
yeah yeah i mean just for this older
syntax
so you'd say list data comma index in
order to have the index as an additional
argument right which is which is not
great but if we think that we're going
to you know if we think that in the next
version or something we're going to have
this beautiful supply thing then it's
not that bad either
i agree
why break compatibility with the
previous thing for a notation that's not
going to work long term anyway
sure yeah
all right but so that puts pressure on
here for
you know
we got to think through this
contextualized variables thing
are we fine with the actual strings
being used
things like level negative level level
pair
i don't see why not
okay
okay
um
right but we need to push forward on
getting
i mean how how much of an inventory of
where we could use the supplied concept
do we have
system-wide so to speak
i think just the
ref page
which is like the core functional
language programming stuff
which route page the webpage for
supplies
where's the rule stuff
right i didn't do that okay
um
okay
i mean there's all kinds of weird places
this could be used i mean like like for
instance
oh i mean there's all kinds of weird
things like switch statements where you
could say which elements of the switch
statement you're in
that's kind of crazy
yeah i don't even know what that means
well i mean
i guess the point is
never mind
um
never mind i mean you've lexically
determined that anyway
um
so i mean qualitatively what this is for
and and this relates to our next meeting
probably i mean as you're walking
through a symbolic expression
this is kind of telling you which might
be a a being created symbolic expression
it's kind of telling you where you are
this is the context of where you are in
that traversal i think is that right
that's what all these functions are
doing
in some way
for example nest
you're constructing
right
um
okay well look
we're wimping a little bit for this
version
here but i think
right i mean one question is
if we did supply without
the dollar dollar
contextualized whatever is it still
useful
yes
we really want the other stuff
i mean
you know particularly if we had a nice
short name for supplied
you know i think it could be
um and then we see how it goes in terms
of
its use because the other case of it
that the other syntax for it
is merely a shortening isn't it
there's nothing you can achieve with it
you cannot achieve with supply
there are things that each of them can
achieve that the other can't
okay what kind of dollar dollar thing
achieve
for one it can be used on the right hand
side of a rule
and two it's actually changing the like
say in map
you say map f comma whatever if that f
expression lexically contains
the contextual variable then that means
you're changing the f that you're
mapping yeah okay
which is a slightly obscure operation
i mean that i mean that way things like
mapping over a held expression still
just like work
yes i realize
but the supply thing's already useful
and by the way
presumably plugs directly into various
kinds of progress reporting and so on
to the extent these elements are
implementable
well that's a question i don't know the
answer to that
and you guys should look at that
well we've clearly got more to discuss
on this this is a very good concept the
whole thing is a good concept
all right i think we've got to go here
and some of you are also in the next
meeting
um
yeah this one is sort of more
uh i i you know this is not something i
think we we should be right now yeah um
i mean yeah if we if we need to end we i
mean
like i said none of these the lambda
discussion might be a bit interesting uh
to mark and tom as well as christopher
right we were asking about how how
you know what notations do other fun
languages have for lambda because
you know we were
and like what might be a match fix
notation that we could use
assuming we want yet another
syntax for the main problem being
how do you get
given all the all the um
precedence issues i mean this doesn't
cut it obviously because that's got as
many parentheses as anything
yep
it's kind of like
you know
you launch with a lambda
and then you have to
you know i don't know what you do to
delimit it
i mean i kind of worry a little bit
about having you know
having
another syntax for this where it's not
clear what the difference is i mean i
think either we say
this is the new syntax you know that's
replacing ampersand
which is kind of dramatic
or or it's or it's uh
you know people are just going to be
confused
well i don't know about that i think the
arrow doesn't isn't confusing
um
confusion fusion
you know f at x
you know x slash f that does not lead to
a lot of confusion
right but but it's also
you know i feel like
if they're then like now four different
syntaxes for writing pure functions you
can write it with function you can write
it with the fancy arrow you can write it
with ampersand and then now you can
write it with
some prefix ampersand
sorry
yeah i mean right so i i don't feel like
full form counts right full form right
everything has a full form
so right so like at the summer school
for example like people like you know
people who are like learning the
language and people still ask me like oh
when should i write out
function full form versus when should i
use the arrow versus once i use the
ampersand and it's like you know you
might think oh well it's obvious but
everyone's most convenient but i think
just having
you know different options already kind
of confuses people
well i mean
[Music]
well i don't think it's whichever is
most convenient right it's do you do you
want named variables or not right i mean
you use ampersand when you're using slot
and you use the arrow when you're using
you know bound variables
when do you use the arrow versus writing
out function i mean for me it's when
basically the precedence you know
depends on how the precedence works
right but yeah
also function for three arguments or or
or yes right so you have to use function
for three arguments
and also
you know when i want to make it look
more mathy i use the the arrow fancy
arrow
and also when it happens to be the you
know an argument of a function like nest
graph or something or nest or something
where there's no precedence issue
great
um
the point is just that these are
distinctions that are you know if you
just showed someone not familiar with
the language you know here are the
syntaxes for pure functions it's not
immediately obvious why you'd need these
and where you'd use them that's just my
point
right and and and christopher you you
weren't here for the previous round of
the discussion but my opening gambit in
that discussion was
what exactly are we trying to achieve
with yet another
notation for function so
right
yeah well okay i mean i was thinking if
we could actually get a thing that
looked like a lambda it might be nice
but it doesn't look like that
syntactically you know that precedence
wise works
right we need to go to the next meeting
okay so